any last words come closer
closer oh wait you got some on your tie
right there
yes see aunt sue's glad to be a part of
this
i'm sorry it's oh i love surprises
freaking excited
because they don't know
sue what are you doing well yep
my hips have clenched oh god i got
cramps in my butt
anyone else i'm sorry oh i'm sorry
i'm just so freaking excited
[Applause]
[Music]
did you throw america's favorite dessert
at my head
sorry her name is
[Music]
my panic attacks having a panic attack
it's called a panic anec attack it's
worse
sam penelope sit down please have a seat
penelope i am running this show
not you i shouldn't say this but you are
driving me nuts
oh i drive myself nuts drive myself
actually in a nut car so
my car's a nut i do promotional work for
planners so
mr peanut on wheels the windshield is a
monocle and the convertible roof is a
top hat so
it's parked outside sit
i think we could all use a break you
know what i've got a good idea i'll play
a dvd
it'll help you find ways to relieve
stress in situations like this these
methods
really work too
[Music]
welcome everyone has stress two
sisters do as sisters should
we're all together sisters
i'm jennis
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
sisters always stick together even when
they
fall in love like with my boyfriend
with my husband
with my fiancee
[Music]
i learned something every day at target
yesterday i learned that coca-cola is
dark brown
be 441 what that
cannot be right uh oh you're correct
you know what that means i get to do
something very rare
fine voids take a lot of energy i think
i need half of an ailment
it worked successfully
your real total is 38.51 and here's a
wing for free
i'll just pay cash you can use your damn
but if it's easier don't worry i will
cross my eyes so i can't see your secret
code
[Laughter]
if you're still here thanks for coming
[Applause]
[Music]
you